the one thing i am concerned about is
the lack of a consistent run game
because everything can't as you know
chris everything can't be on the
quarterback he's gonna have to make sure
that they implement that run game and
and see what happens but i thought he
was really good i thought he controlled
everything you know being able to throw
the ball down the field and make big
plays come on that opens up everything
else underneath
go ahead
yeah i mean rodney you're right there
was no run game tonight the bears have
been a tough match-up for them as far as
running the ball over the last few years
they've got a lot of big people up front
no doubt i think the cool thing is and
you guys saw it in person and i don't
know you tell me what matthew stafford's
arm looked like in person but regardless
they the different thing about the rams
i think as we go forward this year when
they couldn't run the ball in the past
the offense fell flat now we saw tonight
yeah they couldn't run the ball but
that's not the only thing about this
offense now with matthew stafford he can
bring a drop back pass element to them
that they did not have and of course the
big play ball is really going to scare
defenses and help that run game find its
footing here as we go without cam akers
and company
and chris stafford got the ball to
everybody it was just whoever he wanted
to get it to whenever he wanted to get
it to him which of the playmakers caught
your eye
i would say van jefferson the fact that
he's the third wide receiver second year
guy just being able to make big plays on
a stage like this and be able to haul in
the ball and make those plays i thought
this young man was terrific i know they
brought in deshawn jackson he's a guy
that he's made a lot of big plays in his
life but he's he's always injured so if
you can get a young guy like a van
jefferson to come in and just you know
be able to make those contributions and
tyler higbee was another guy i mean i
think this is this one this tight end
he's very capable of catching 70 passes
800 yards
six six to eight touchdowns let's hear
from the head coach you're with sean
mcvay on some of their great playmakers
i'm more worried about you know being
able to move the ball and score points
and so uh you do want to be cognizant of
that i think the best offenses have the
ability to do both but i think it was
more a result of minimal plays um but
also being able to you know run some
things that we thought was the the
smartest way to be able to move the
football against a really tough defense
they did a good job being able to be
stout at the point of attacking some of
the runs and they were doing some things
that kind of forced us to shift in the
direction of throwing a little bit early
on and then i thought the balance got
back to kind of what we won in that
second half but it was uh you know
they're tough defense they've done a
great job they've got great personnel
and that's always a factor for us for
sure
explosive plays in the first game that
was exactly what we had wanted and it
was from a bunch of different guys you
look at van you look at cooper tyler
higby has what i think was a 37-yard
catch um you know and then what an
individual effort on the third down
along for cooper when we throw in the
little bubble screen but
robert woods made a lot of plays i
thought a lot of different guys made
some great contributions and we still
have some things that we can improve on
but i was really pleased with the
offensive line as well to go against
that defense those guys uh that
personnel when you're talking about
khalil mack robert quinn got a ton of
respect for akeem hicks and so for those
guys to come away with just that one
sack when we were backed up uh is a real
credit to them and uh was very pleased
with them as a whole
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports